All sessions have a file system backing them that can
be accessed. If you go to the URL that is
here's a previous run, for example, that we generated a
comic book from. If we open in a new tab
that same URL but we remove the webpage part so
that we just access the root directory of that session
we can access the file system itself for that session
Now this comes with a number of interesting features. First
of all, we can download the entire directory as a
zip file. We can look at any markdown files
we can look at any HTML files, uh, and directly
view them, of course. And we can also view uh
markdown files. As either markdown
which this will cause download, or you can view the
markdown files as HTML files that does a dynamic rendering
You can also view them as text files. If you
this is handy if you want to view the markdown
source in a way that won't trigger a download for
your browser. And you can also view markdown files as
PDFs, and that also does a dynamic rendering of the
markdown file into PDF format. Additionally
the file system has built-in Git support, so you can
View the current status you can. Commit the directory
If you're not aware, Git is a version control system
for file systems, so that it's basically like a time
machine so that you can track all of the file
changes and if needed rollback. Um, accessing
the root file system for any given session via this
interface gives you a powerful backdoor
into the system functionality. Um, and provides
a good level of hackability and transparency for any of
the cognotic applications. Finally, I'd like to
point out that the physical location of the file system
is shown here. Uh, so if you want, you can
mount this with a development environment or you can open
it in the file system explorer or whatever you want
to do. I hope that functionality
is useful to you.